Speaker 1: Because of all the things that are
constantly going on in the world and also because
gay marriage is now legal nationally in the United
States, sometimes it's easy to get the sense that
the old school violent homophobia of like
kill the gays is over in the United States.
It is not over. And I'm going to play some video
for you today of a Christian pastor in Arlington,
Texas, who wants gay people killed and is very
much against the pride parade. There was a city
council meeting in Arlington, Texas. The point of
it was let's hear comments about whatever is on
people's minds. And this Christian pastor is very
much against the pride parade. These exist all
over the country. They're generally supportive
of LGBT rights. Pretty uncontroversial at this
point in time. And this homophobic MAGA preacher
in Arlington, Texas, show up, shows up and says
gays are an abomination, they should be executed.
I mean, listen, that's what God says. So listen
to this. This is still very much a thing. And
the scariest part is you'll hear people in the
crowd going, yep, I'm right, they agree with it.
Speaker 5: According to God, we should pray, pray,
not celebrate it. We should humble ourselves
as virtually the whole room said that we
were a nation under God, according to the
American flag, and we were a state under
God. We're in the Texas flag. We should
humble ourselves to what the Bible says
and not what a small minority here that is a
bully would say. And then in June of 2020, Mayor
Jeff Williams officially announced he said it's
a pride month in June for the city of Arlington.
But I don't understand why we celebrate what
used to be a crime and not long ago. Yup. Yup.
Speaker 1: You hear those people? Yep.
Speaker 5: According to the Texas College
and Section 21, not to be a respectful homosexual
context. A person commits an offense if he engages
in deviant sexual intercourse with
another individual of the same sex.
In fact, that is still on the books today, even
though Lawrence versus Texas overruled that 2003.
But God has already ruled that murder, adultery,
witchcraft, rape, bestiality and homosexuality
are crimes worthy of capital punishment. But
then again, in 2013, the Bible says that a man
also like mankind, as he lay him with a woman
and both of them committed an abomination.
They so certainly that and then what should.
Speaker 1: Be they should be put to death.
And people in the crowd say aye.
Speaker 5: Men condemned. ROMANS
One says that men with men are
worthy of death. Peter, Chapter two
warns and says that in turning the cities
of Solomon, more houses condemned them as an
overthrow, making them example those that average
limb ungodly God delivered just like sex with the
filthy conversation.
Speaker 1:
It is 2022 and they're still talking about death
for gay people. You know, back in 2008, I would do
interviews like this where people would say this
stuff, but we like to believe it's not going on
anymore. And he kept going with the homophobic
stuff and the crowd kept saying, Yep, yep.
Speaker 5: Here in the CDC, homosexual men are
230 times more likely to get HIV than straight
men. Yeah, I don't know why we promote disease
and AIDS in our community. You're occasionally,
according to this article, is self-reported
claims that LGBT have an average of 20 to 150
children same things and including they come
in an average of 154 hours a year. Now, here's
the thing. They say that they love so much, but
they need children. Yep. That's just the hatred.
Speaker 1: So this is the gays or
pedophiles thing, which is like this is
old school homophobia. Now, I know many of
you will say, David, you know, Leviticus,
which they often cite. Leviticus also says eating
shrimp is an abomination, but they all eat shrimp.
What's up with that? And it's true. If you look
at Leviticus, it does say that when you eat from
the waters whatsoever hath fins and scales in the
waters, them shall eat and all that have not fins
and scales. They shall be an abomination unto you.
That's what Leviticus says. And you would say,
Well, but how can they point to Leviticus for
the anti-gay stuff? But then they ignore all
these other parts of Leviticus. They simply talk
about the New Covenant. They they figured it out,
guys. They have a response to this. They
say, no, no, no, no, no. We Christians, we
have been promised the New Covenant, which was
instituted at the Last Supper as part of the
Eucharist. And it replaces the dietary law, but
it didn't replace the anti-gay parts. So they
they they've got an answer for that. I know
you and I would look at it and we would say how
hypocritical they'll be picking and choosing. But
no. And in fact, they won't just say Leviticus.
The anti-gay stuff. They'll talk about what's
in Timothy and what's in Corinthians and on
and on and on from the New Testament. So I know
that it doesn't make any sense. It's hypocrisy,
it's picking and choosing. It's all this stuff
that we're very used to. But at the same time,
at the same time, they are continuing,
even though it's 20, 22. Horrifying stuff.